mattias I'd like to ask keep up working
festival with Marion Cotillard cuz I
believe that was about the first five
minutes for that first scene that you
shot together you kind of were scared
above her any kind of way tell me what
happened yeah well it was that I wasn't
scared but the first the very first
scene was shot together was I think the
second week of the shoot and I knew she
was exhausted because she just had a
baby and she was shooting Batman she was
going back and forth so that was kind of
exhausting for her and so first day I
come to said and everybody's setting up
and I see her sitting in a wheelchair
with the hair down it was like
completely exhausting I was like oh my
god what's going on this I don't know so
I said hi to her she's a great start
here we go
and then yeah then she really surprised
me she took me by surprise the very
first rehearsal and yeah and from there
on I realized okay she's just oh she's
just sucked in and she's ready to go and
then from the very first rehearsal it
was clear to me that we were off for a
very particular journey and we had a
very genuine organic connection you can
see that your role is well you really /
- the night - the meticulous sort of
preparation in for as well those events
in terms of who your character is and
also in terms of your physicality as
well as you have done with many of your
roles I think of things like bullhead
where you completely change your blue as
well didn't you for that and you kind of
done a similar thing for rust and bone
haven't you tell me a little bit about
what was involved in that for you well
obviously the the two characters you
were referring to are very physical in
the sense that the characters express
themselves more through their
physicality than verbally so there's a
similarity there but to me both
characters are extremely different in
the way they approach life in the way
they feel about life and the way they
deal with life so for rust and bone
there wasn't a norm there was a big
physical preparation required so Jacques
wanted me to grow a little belly but to
look strong at the same time not fit not
some guy that spent hours in the gym
daily not someone who's who's was eating
bad who's who looks pretty much
unhealthy because he doesn't have the
means to eat properly and so I had to
box of course for the for the part and
we rehearsed the fighting sequences over
and over again because they had to be
really brutal and pretty intense so we
had to be really well prepared so
there's no accidents on set these guys
in front of me were pretty pretty scary
I can tell so that was one part of the
preparation was the physical part and
the other part is just making sure that
by the time you start shooting you're in
the in the right state of mind and in
the right state of being to be able to
release whatever emotion needs to be
released in the instant in the scene
itself so it's just about being being
open being being sensitive and and ready
to to to be in the instant you happy
very prepared as well to work with the
director
Shaku no no tell me a bit about how you
worked together well Jacques he's uh
he's an artist and he's he's permanently
permanently looking for life in the
moment itself for him make moviemaking
for him is is a very organic thing so he
wants to bring it to life in the moment
itself so he doesn't have preconceptions
about his scene of course he wrote the
screenplay so he knows about his
characters he knows about the energy
that he wants but then it's it's trying
to bring it to life in the moment that
you're on set in those specific
circumstances so he's a very generous
director he gives you a lot of freedom
he gives you a lot of things but he
wants you to propose him a lot of things
so they feed him so that brings his
ideas to another place and then so it's
a permanent exchange so that is that is
extremely exciting and he sees yeah he's
one of a kind he's really one of a kind
and he's very sensitive very intelligent
has a great sense of humor
I think that is that is the magical key
I guess having a great sense of humor if
you like to work with him again then
absolutely no doubt about it
and you guys you're working with Marian
again aren't you well we shot we shot we
wrapped it up already yeah we shot it in
in June but I don't have any scenes with
her no no my wife in the film is Zoe
Saldana which is not it's quite amazing
as well yeah yeah and you're working
with me direct my husband aren't you oh
yes
working and mariana being directive like
you it was a lot of fun Gilman's is a
very first of all he's a very talented
director and second of all he's just a
very kind passionate human being and so
that's always fun to work with
it has a very funky energy right they're
coming to get me Epsilon I gotta go
so no he sees funnies he sharp he sees
everything I like about people New York
well what is it like shooting in New
York that's probably every young actors
or European I don't know everybody to me
that's funny you know New York is just a
mythical city especially for films as
well so many great films have been shot
there and and to shoot in Brooklyn in a
film which is set in the 70s it's
amazing I loved everything about it yeah
and finally if I remade Belgium's really
yes
no we shot that a year and a half ago
and probably they're releasing it in
April yeah so that's that's a long time
ago that's I shot rust and bone already
and that came out so it feels weird
talking about a film that I've shot a
year and a half ago and that still
didn't came out but I'm excited to see
it yeah apparently they had a screening
last week I think it's some kind of
industry screening last week in LA and
everybody really responded well to it so
I'm looking forward
you